he suffers more than necessary
who suffers before it is necessary
it is not the man who has too little
but the man who craves more that is poor
anger
if not restrained
is frequently more hurtful to us
than the injury that provokes it
if you really want to escape the things
that harass you
what you're needing is not to be in a
different place
but to be a different person
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
if a man knows not to which port he
sails
no wind is favorable
all cruelty springs from weakness
[Music]
there is no easy way from the earth to
the stars
[Music]
life is like a play
it's not the length but the excellence
of the acting that matters
difficulties strengthen the mind
as labor does the body
you act like mortals in all that you
fear
and like immortals in all that you
desire
sometimes even to live
is an act of courage
it is the power of the mind to be
unconquerable
the life we receive is not short
but we make it so
we are not ill-provided but use what we
have wastefully
the greatest blessings of mankind are
within us
and within our reach
a wise man is content with his lot
whatever it may be
without wishing for what he has not
begin at once to live
and count each separate day as a
separate life
he who is brave
is free
until we have begun to go without them
we fail to realize how unnecessary many
things are
we've been using them not because we
needed them
but because we had them
what need is there to weep over parts of
life the whole of it calls for tears
no man was ever wise by chance
they lose the day in expectation of the
night
and the night in fear of the dawn
associate with people who are likely to
improve you
i shall never be ashamed of citing a bad
author
if the line is good
only time can heal what reason cannot
most powerful is he who has himself in
his own power
if you live in harmony with nature
you will never be poor
if you live according to what others
think
you will never be rich
enjoy present pleasures in such a way as
not to injure future ones
wealth is the slave of a wise man
the master of a fool
as long as you live
keep learning how to live
people are frugal in guarding their
personal property
but as soon as it comes to squandering
time
they are most wasteful of the one thing
in which it is right to be stingy
the sun also shines
on the wicked
every new beginning comes from some
other beginnings end
leisure without books is death
and burial of a man alive
often a very old man has no other proof
of his long life than his
age we are more often frightened than
hurt
and we suffer more from imagination than
from reality
religion is regarded by the common
people as true
by the wisest false
and by rulers as useful
a gift consists not in what is done or
given but in the intention of the giver
or doer
we learn not in school
but in
life life is long
if you know how to use it
nothing is more honorable than a
grateful heart
there is no genius
without a touch of madness
to wish to be well
is a part of becoming
well but life is very short and anxious
for those who forget the past
neglect the present
and fear the future
while we wait for life
life passes
it does not matter how many books you
have
but how good the books are
it is difficult to bring people to
goodness with lessons
but it is easy to do so by example
it is a tough road that leads to the
heights of greatness
he who has injured thee
was either stronger or weaker than thee
if weaker spare him
if stronger
spare thyself
it is more civilized to make fun of life
than to bewail it
whatever can happen at any time can
happen today
[Music]
the part of life we really live is small
for all the rest of existence is not
life
but merely time
to win true freedom
you must be a slave to philosophy
[Music]
of this one thing
make sure against your dying day
that your faults die before you do
there is no enjoying the possession of
anything valuable
unless one has someone to share it with
to be always fortunate and to pass
through life with the soul that has
never known sorrow
is to be ignorant of one half of nature
[Music]
the best ideas are common property
to be everywhere
is to be nowhere
no man is crushed by misfortune unless
he has first been deceived by prosperity
you are lonely
not because no one needs you but because
you care about who is next to you
the main feature of weak people is
the fear of saying what you think is
right
it is quality rather than quantity that
matters
[Music]
everyone prefers belief to the exercise
of judgment
[Music]
gold is tested by fire
women by gold
and man by women and suffering
if we could be satisfied with anything
we should have been satisfied long ago
what really ruins our character is the
fact that none of us looks back over his
life
when a person spends all his time in
foreign travel
he ends by having many acquaintances
but no friends